zach davies uh one-on-one with a bloated
era after that rough one against
pittsburgh but one really good start one
ugly one as he takes the mound here this
afternoon you see he's not gonna blow
them away with velocity average fastball
coming in at 87 miles per hour and the
pitch
and he walked him
and keep your eyes on acuna there he is
already on first base he's dangerous
when he gets on the base pass out on the
field everything he does so all eyes on
him
here's freeman now
hits it hard on the ground sogart
sliding stop flips to first
freeman attacks early well positioned i
mean
so guard strong to the full side feel
great if you need me i'm in
swinging a little roller along first
davies will take it himself steps on the
bag
and that is the end kyle wright who gets
the surprise start for the braves today
yeah he does look they we knew we'd need
depth this year from the start rotation
here's kyle you see those numbers last
year the last three starts to me is when
you see the k to base on ball ratio
today is a perfect example
music swing and a ball ripped down
towards left center field and that
little bang up against the bricks half
with a big turn but it's collected by
ozuna it's a long loud single for ian
hat with half aboard here is contreras
right the 3-2
and that one hit him but he gets punked
again three fielders to the right of
second with peterson up here two on two
out
in the air that should be a can of corn
for ender and ciarte and kyle wright
works around two on nobody out and the
cubs fail to score again in the first
inning
from this side a little bit of power
probably enough to keep him doing it
back to the mound davies handles it
and all these is out
adrianza waiting and one out man at
first and a 2-2
swaying and a miss
and he got him to swing over top the
styrofoam cup again tough guy to strike
out tough guy to fool
popped up right side sogard and buy it
there's hobby coming in and fix the jump
catch
inside did it hit him yeah it did
kyle wright hits javi baez
so the leadoff man is aboard
and now it's jason hayward baez at first
nobody out and that one's hit hard and
event is hitting the right field
around second on his way to third throw
cut off it's a single for hayward
back-to-back innings
where the first two guys reach
subs in the first two innings have their
second scoring opportunity
that one is smoked out towards right
center field and ciarte on the move wind
knocking it down he makes the catch
tagging from third
is baez and the cubs are on the board it
is one nothing as sogar delivers a run
the
hit on the ground up the middle sliding
stand so
first in time they stole a hit from the
pitcher
bidding for his first career hit eric
sogart with a nice range you play
sogart having himself a nice day a
couple really good plays in the field
and an rbi thus far
here's a change up down low to freddie
freeman and he draws the walk two down
marcel ozuna comes up
there's a rifle shot into left center
field that's down for a hit peterson
will cut it off freddie will stop at
second and the braves have a two-out
rally so let's see how the braves fare
with a runner in scoring position it's a
two-out situation for darneau
no balls in a strike
and a shot toward left peterson plays it
on a short hop can't get the ball out of
his glove and freeman will score
standing up thank you very much jack
peterson
fumbled and left darno with a base hit
atlanta cashes in a walk and we're tied
in a run a piece looks to me like the
short hops what got peterson not just
the bobble well that's a tough play i
mean he's coming in to catch that ball
at the last second you realize i'm not
going to
and does a good job just keep it in
front of you
one hit softly to third round charges
bare hands slangs pick ow
nice play both ends of it
brian able to grab it rizzo able to pick
it
yeah swinging butt there he couldn't
have rolled it out there any better than
swanson did brian got a real nice
break on this ball you'll see it here
from this angle katana in a hurry and
with rizz over there generally it's
somewhere in the area code and he's
going to pick it
two on pitch that's lofted out towards
left and that's in for an opposite field
base hit nice two out single out of
bender ray's making some racket now with
two down just like they did in the third
inning we'll see if they can turn it
into a run but we run into kyle right
now the pitch
is hit hard that's a fair ball down the
left field line andrew around second on
his way to third peterson got it bobbles
it again
and ender will stop at third as kyle
wright has a two-out double and did
ender hurt himself he might have i guess
ender tweaked something going from
second to third otherwise you'd think he
might have had a chance to score on that
play so haredi is at third right at
second his first major league hit and a
great chance with two outs for the
braves to take the lead here ronald has
walked and popped out payoff
line drive in a right field a base hit
that wasn't a strike but that's going to
score heredia that's going to score
right and ronald acuna jr with two outs
has given the braves a three to one lead
he reached out and smoked that ball into
right field freddie with such a quick
bat looking at a 1-1 count here it is
from davies
chopper over the mound going hard to his
right gloving and throwing now sogar
that's not in time over at first base
the inning continues freddie freeman
hustling down the line acuna is at
second freddy's at first and ozuna's
coming up
that ball's hit hard to short again a
stumble by bias and the throw to the
plate is going to be
dropped and safe acuna came flying
around third
baez
stunned that he was trying to score on
the play threw the ball low to contreras
who couldn't hang on ronald didn't touch
the plate on the first go by but as the
ball trickled away went back and stepped
on the dish and atlanta has a fourth run
and back-to-back walks put runners first
and second with one out and guillermo
herrera will be the batter out of ready
and deals runners go and the pitch is in
the upgrade at third got him strike him
out throw him out
so the braves get aggressive wilson
contreras and jason adam make him pay
and it'll be contreras third time around
the cubs can inflict a little damage
here
in the air
towering fly ball left field ozil
turning looking out here
i mean an absolute blast from contreras
that was as high as it was far his third
of the year
and the cups within two it's 4-2 there's
a little third time around magic for you
contreras the strikeout throw out double
play and then the big bat shows up
one ball one strike
ozzy serves that ball into left center
field that's going to get down for a hit
peterson bobbles that helmet off ozzy he
stands at second boy peterson's been an
adventure defensively hadn't he good
swing by ozzy taking it the other way a
double and a walk and adrianza is the
hitter first and third against maples
the pitch
is in the air towards center it's
shallow
and john peterson comes on takes a look
at the baseball and ozzie's going to
streak home and score standing up so
adrianza puts it in play does what he's
supposed to do atlanta gets a sacrifice
fly
and atlanta adds to the lead 5-2 freeman
waits for brothers the 2-1
freeman rips that left center field
towards the gap peterson
chuck lays out steals extra bases
from freddie freeman what a play by jack
peterson rex brothers loves it
[Music]
and there is no padding on the kneecap
he can't continue george poulos waved
off ozzy albee's
that's one of the toughest guys in the
game when he leaves you know he's smart
and hopefully that won't swell up on
aussie albies so bryant will come to the
dish with two on
and two outs bottom of the ninth five
two braves
lefty sets and deals
and it's ball four they're loaded up
so here's the situation jack peterson
was hoping for he wants to face
left-handers he wants to be an everyday
guy
tying runs on base
winning run at the plate
another 2-2
swing and a miss it all started with a
fastball will smith got ahead with two
strikes then finished him with the
slider and the braves finish off the
cubs jeff but not without some ninth
inning drama game one goes atlanta's way
5-2 your score